"Ah ! Encore un YouTubeur payé par une marque pour mettre en avant un produit"
Ben non je... je bois de l'eau en fait ! "Combien ils t'ont payé San Pellegrino hein?! "
"10 000 ? 20 000? COMBIEN?" Et oh ça va là ?
Les amis aujourd'hui je veux vous raconter des anecdotes sur les OP spé
Qu'est ce qu'une OP spé ? Une OP spé c'est quand un youtubeur travaille avec une marque pour faire une vidéo
sponsorisée voilà. J'ai des anecdotes trop marrantes à vous raconter sur ça, mais avant il faut que je vous explique quelques trucs pour vous puissiez
comprendre les anecdotes. C'est bien comme ça ça me permet de casser quelques fausses idées reçues et
d'apporter un peu plus de lumière et de transparence sur ce sujet qui fait tant parmi de Youtube aujourd'hui.
Ah, les youtubeurs adorent l'argent c'est bien connu.
C'est une blague...c'est une blague...c'est une blague c'est bon... Quasiment tous les youtubeurs que vous connaissez aujourd'hui travaillent avec une régie publicitaire
Cette régie va être chargée de lui trouver des vidéos sponsorisées à faire, alors ça peut aller dans les deux sens par exemple on a euh...
Euh...
Ah ! "Et Lucas y'a..." C'est quoi cette marque ? ... "King d'home", ah c'est un jeu de mots !
y'a king d'home qui veut mettre en avant ses ventilateurs, et leur budget c'est 10 000 euros t'as une idée de vidéos qui peut être cool ?
Là je réponds oui si j'ai une idée, et qu'il y a un truc cool à faire autour des ventilateurs, en l'occurrence je réponds archi non
Autre scénario possible : "Hey la régie !
J'ai découvert la marque king d'home ils font des super ventilateurs, et j'aimerais bien faire une vidéo autour de leurs produits contre un peu de..."
Je suis youtubeur j'aime l'argent. Et là, la régie va contacter la marque, et leur proposer de faire une vidéo
en collaboration avec Squeezie contre de l'argent pour mettre en avant leurs ventilateurs, Voilà ! Alors ce que j'ai dit ça peut paraître évident et basique pour certains
(qui ont fait école de commerce) mais pour tous les autres je vous assure je croise plein de gens qui n'ont aucune idée de comment
ça se passe ils croient même des fois qu'on m'oblige
à mettre des trucs en avant j'ai acheté une putain de San pé (San Pellegrino) parce que j'adore la San pé, ils ne m'ont pas payé, payez moi si vous voulez
je prends hein mais tout n'est pas forcément du placement. J'aurais pu être payé par San pé pour mettre en avant san pellegrino par exemple
mais c'est pas le cas mais si c'était le cas j'aurais été obligé de le préciser en haut de la description et aussi de cocher
la case vous savez où il y a ça qui apparaît là
s'il n'y a pas ça sur une vidéo c'est que normalement il contient pas de placement de produit ou alors le youtubeur est un petit
cachottier et il peut lui arriver du malheur parce que tout ça c'est contrôlé par le gouvernement ce qu'il fait ça s'appelle alors de la
publicité déguisée et ça c'est puni par la loi j'ai quasi fini je suis désolé c'est hyper chiant j'ai une précision à apporter, c'est que
quand elle est super fait une vidéo avec une marque elle un droit de regard sur ce que le youtubeur  a fait c'est à dire
qu'avant de mettre la vidéo en ligne le youtubeur lui envoie
pour qu'elle valide bien tout ce qu'il y a dedans imaginons je sais pas un youtubeur par exemple a filmé une blague très limite dans sa
vidéo je sais pas moi des propos
racistes par exemple le pire truc la marque a droit de dire ah bah nan là tu ta fiche avec nous
nous on cautionne pas que tu dises des trucs pareils alors ça dégage les amis la première anecdote elle est géniale et tout est ma
faute la marque n'a rien fait c'est moi qui ai merdé mais j'étais jeune
est ce que cette vidéo dit quelque chose à des gens parmi vous
ça fait presque trois ans déjà ça passe vite. Pour ceux qui me suivaient à l'époque j'avais mis cette vidéo en ligne puis je l'avais
supprimer et je l'avais remis en ligne plus tard mais je n'ai jamais expliqué pourquoi aujourd'hui en 2018 je vais
résoudre ce mystère devant vos yeux et vous allez rire cette vidéo était
sponsorisé par disney infinity 3.0 je sais plus si c'était une agence ou disney en direct mais bref j'avais dit oui pour faire une vidéo sur
leur jeu bon jeu bon j'avais mes raisons je sais pas pourquoi j'ai fait ça
je sais pas
2015 j'étais un peu un chien on va pas se mentir. 2015 c'était un autre game les op clairement tout ce qu'ils aient développé à chaque fois
c'était de la merde y'a pas de grosse vidéo
scénarisé trop ouf et tout à part un peu peut-être sur cyprien gaming et moi sur ma chaise je savais pas faire ça moi juste je
jouais et j'encaissais je tourne la vidéo
c'est pas très amusant ce qui s'y passe mais c'est pas grave clément montrent la vidéo il me dit Lucas c'est pas très amusant ce qui
se passe mais c'est pas grave et il fait le montage regarde la vidéo elle est pas ouf on va pas se mentir parce que
ah bah ce que j'avais fait sur le jeu c'était pas ouf clairement on envoie la vidéo à disney et on attend qu'ils
valident pour que je puisse la mettre en ligne ils mettent 72 heures à validé mais 72h normalement une marque elle met entre
4 et 8 heures la vidéo elle est en non répertoriée et y avait
46 vues, Disney l'a regardé
46 fois avant de la valider ils ont zoomé sur chaque pixel pour voir s'ils avaient pas un truc de cacher et raciste ou
comment ça se passe bref il valide enfin la vidéo mais
petite douille je l'a re regarde une fois avant de la mettre en ligne et je me dis et si je rajoutais un petit effet MLG là
une fois que j'ai gagné la course la plus marrante, "oh la la c'est quoi un effet MLG ?" c'est ça :
C'est souvent utilisé quand un mec vient de faire une action badass dans un jeu, je dis à clément de rajouter ça, il me renvoie la
vidéo mais je ne la refait pas validé par disney non non non, j'ai pas envie d'attendre que 45 personnes de chez disney la voie
la vidéo et ça va décaler tout mon planning moi, j'avais prévu de la mettre en ligne aujourd'hui
l'erreur, il y a donc ceci dans la vidéo que disney n'a pas vu : "1v1 no-scope"
"oooh le no-scope"!!!
Je mets la vidéo en ligne,
et là, je suis pris d'une fatigue monumentale, je ne sais pas pourquoi ! "Le pire moment de l'année pour faire une sieste".
écoutez bien, vraie histoire, la seule sieste que j'ai fait en 2015, c'était celle ci.
Il y en a eu aucune autre ! C'était celle ci : je m'allonge sur mon canapé et je m'endors paisiblement pendant près de deux heures,
à mon réveil, je vois que l'écran de mon téléphone est allumé,
je le prends pour voir ce qui se passe, et là,
47 appels manqués
68 nouveaux messages
j'appelle quelqu'un qui s'appelle Laurent, et qui bosse pour la régie publicitaire qui avait négocié la vidéo sponsorisée avec Disney, et ses premiers mots furent les suivants :
"Lucas on est morts".
Squeezie : "Pourquoi Laurent ?"
Laurent : "lucas tu as mis snoop dog qui fume dans la vidéo !"
Squeezie : "ah mais ça c'est un effet MLG c'est pas..."
Laurent : "ils l'ont pas validé ça Disney, c'était pas dans la version que tu m'as envoyé !"
Squeezie : "aaah yes"
je me sens mal. Vous connaissez Squeezie 2015, face à ça, il y a une réaction tout à fait humaine, et tout à fait compréhensible.
"Eh je m'en bas les c**** OK ? Ils ont accepté de travailler avec moi, ils acceptent ça c'est mon humour ça, OK ? ils ont rien à dire"
"je me tape trois ans après pour avoir dit ça". Laurent m'explique clairement au bout du fil que si je ne supprime pas la vidéo,
nous allons partir en procès, car ce que j'ai fait, est parfaitement illégal. Je vous l'ai dit !
La marque, doit valider la vidéo, avant qu'elles soit mise en ligne, c'est comme ça !
la marque, achète une pub en vrai quand elle fait une OP avec toi, tu peux pas la berner comme ça c'est pas possible,
on reçoit une lettre des avocats de Disney, est-ce que quelque chose de pire peut arriver ? Disney qui t’envoie ses avocats, Disney
Disney, c'étais le plus gros coup de pression de toute ma vie. Je supprime alors la vidéo,
Disney au final ont acceptés qu'on remette la vidéo en ligne, sans l'effet MLG. Voilà, est-ce que face à eux j'étais en posture pour négocier ?
Pas du tout ! j'ai vraiment baissé mon pantalon, j'ai dit : OK, Disney on y va ! la vidéo est toujours en ligne vous pouvez aller la voir,
vous verrez à quel point elle est, (Smoutch)  d'une qualité incroyable,
l'une des plus belles OP SPE de tout YouTube cette vidéo!
Ahhh merde ! ça c'était la plus grosse anecdote, maintenant j'ai quelques trucs un peu plus subtils, mais qui sont très amusants. Une fois avec Cyprien,
on devait faire une vidéo sur Cyprien Gaming pour le jeu
Disney Infinity <3
Décidément, ça n'arrête pas ! Heureusement qu'il n'existe plus ce jeu p****n ! c'était une vidéo gameplay traditionnelle,
comme il y en a des tas sur Youtube, et souvent en fait quand on tournait une vidéo à l'époque sur Cyprien Gaming pour une marque,
il y a des gens de la marque, qui étaient au studio avec nous, et qui nous faisaient un petit brief avant :
"Si vous mettez un truc en avant c'est plutôt ça, parlez pas de ça".
à l'époque c'était pas comme maintenant, les marques elles comprenaient pas qu'il fallait nous laisser faire un peu ce qu'on veut, pour que la vidéo soit
cool, et que ça donne envie de jouer au jeu dans leur intérêt, comme dans le nôtre en fait. Ce jour là, ils nous ont
imposé, non pas de parler de certaines choses, ils nous ont imposé des costumes.
What the f*** ? bah ça peut être drôle après tout, puis si les costumes sont un peu stylé, c'est marrant.
Comme vous pouvez le voir, il n'y avait plus aucune dignité dans nos corps,
tout s'était envolé, et la grosse blague mec c'est que quand on avait mis les costumes, on avait tapé une barre de ouf, parce qu'on ressemblait
à rien mec, téma gros, on dirait un mauvais tapis que j'ai sur le corps, on commence à tourner la vidéo,
on rigole sur les costumes, parce qu'on a des dégaines pas possible, et là les mecs de l'agence nous disent : "ah non non vous avez pas compris vous
pouvez pas dire du mal des costumes là en fait, on les met sur vous pour qu'on en vende derrière". Frère, on dirait que
tu as peint un drap et que tu me l'a mis sur le corps, maintenant tu vas me laisser rigoler de ces costumes de m***e ! mon gars c'est fou !
La marque nous avait obligée à ne pas nous moquer des costumes dans la vidéo, alors déjà, on aurait pu encenser ce costume,
ils en auraient vendus 4 et ensuite c'était une OPE SPE pour le jeu, les costumes là, c'est un traquenard !
Bref, c'était un cauchemar, mais au final ça valait le coup parce que j'ai vu Cyprien dans cette tenue : et ça ça n'a pas de prix.
Autre anecdote, d'une grosse galère qu'on à eu avec Cyprien, on a travaillé vraiment dans le vent, c'est horrible, c'était pour le jeu :
Vous savez ce que je vais dire, encore lui ! Disney Infinity <3 <3
Cette fois, on s'est dit : "bon, les vidéos gameplay ça marche pas, cette fois on va trouver un concept une idée cool, et on va
faire une vraie vidéo sympa, avec de la production et tout", on va créer une histoire entre les personnages pendant une partie de Disney Infinity
comme si à chaque fois que tu retirais une figurine, ou que tu en posais une sur le socle là, elle se parlaient entre elles Cyprien,
écrit la vidéo parce qu'à l'époque, moi j'écrivais rien du tout sur la chaîne. On lance le tournage donc on devait se peindre le visage
en vert, pour ensuite juste avoir nos bouches, et les caler sur les personnages, en fait sur les figurines. John montre la vidéo, c'est celui
qui faisait tout les montages des Cyprien Gaming à l'époque, On l'envoie à Disney et ils trouvent ça très drôle, et ils valident mais la vidéo n'est jamais
sortie. Pourquoi ? parce que quand Disney France l'a validé, ils l'ont envoyée à Disney Etats-Unis, mais Disney Etats-Unis n'ont pas aimé
les Etats-Unis ont dit : "mais vous avez pas le droit de faire parler les personnages de Marvel dans la vidéo", parce que oui, on avait
mis nos bouches sur Loki, sur Thor, sur Spider-Man et tout, et on n'a pas le droit de les faire parler
en fait et les faire dire ce qu'on veut, sauf que si on l'avait su au début, y aurait pas eu de problème. Mais on l'a su
une fois qu'on avait TOUT FAIT ! la vidéo elle était prête à sortir ! Au moment où je tourne là, je l'ai pas la vidéo mais je
vais la retrouver, et petite ellipse, on va la regarder ensemble, c'est parti :
Regardez ce que y a sur ma boite mail John m'a envoyé une petite
pastille de cette vidéo en fait on n'a pas la vidéo entière mais on a une version où il a bougé les bouches de deux manières différentes
et en fait Disney devait choisir la manière qu'ils préféraient mais comme vous savez au final ils en ont préféré aucune
Clip Disney Infinity là on ressort un doss' mec ça ça date de
2013 y a cinq ans ne soyez donc pas surpris si l'humour n'est pas fou et si mon jeu d'acteur n'est pas fou non plus
c'est parti
il est pas mal
Bien sûr, il a le style mon gars, il est pas mal il a des ailes par contre il y a pas de... il
y a pas de bâton ?
Non ok ça commence tiens tu es nouveau toi aussi ? oui moi aussi je viens d'arriver *rires*
est ce que j'ai essayé de faire une voix de renoi ? est ce que c'est ça que j'essayais de faire là ? c'est scandaleux mec !
Attends une seconde, je suis en train de me faire
engueuler par un mec qui vole grâce à des ailes en plastiques dans le dos, c'est ça ? et moi par un mec qui joue encore avec
un bâton comme quand j'avais 6 ans quoi
C'est peut-être bien qu'il soit jamais sorti hein ?  Salut black widow je m'élance vers toi pour... pour savoir si éventuellement tu aimerais s... sortir avec moi
un vhbv quoi ce soir hein euh...
commence par mettre autre chose qu'un vulgaire pyjama et on verra peut-être
(OOOOOOOOOOOOhhh)
ça c'est de la Punchline de 2013 mon pote ! Ouais, bah bah riez les gars mais en attendant elle je suis sûr que dans cette position
elle a... elle a une crampe au bras ! Eh c'est pas mal en vrai ce passage là !
où alors je ne suis pas du tout objectif
Loki mon frère reviens avec moi à Asguard, nous pourrons régner ensemble sur ce magnifique royaume
tu as eu le marteau, et moi le bâton Thor, tu comprends ?
On se moque de moi depuis je suis gamin.
Mais il est très bien ton bâton tu peux faire plein de trucs avec.
(hahaha)
En vrai c'est un peu drôle ! voilà c'est le vieux doss' qui n'est jamais sorti
et du coup je le sors
cinq ans après, en vrai c'était pas mal pour l'époque franchement je suis que les gens auraient bien aimé
Peut-être que je me trompe. J'AI l'anecdote sur la meilleure OP que j'ai fait à l'heure actuelle sur la chaîne s'était
Overwatch Rap Battle un clip, un clash entre les persos d'Overwatch c'était génial tout le processus créatif qui y a eu pour arriver à ce résultat.
c'était très long c'était des mois et des mois de travail il y a vraiment beaucoup de gens qui ont bossé là dessus et qui ont tout donné
pour atteindre un tel résultat, et je suis très content de cette OP le script est écrit, on le fait valider à Blizzard
Blizzard France nous dit "c'est génial il n'y a pas de soucis." Alors nous on enregistre la musique, Alors nous on tourne le clip,
Alors nous on monte le clip. Mais il y a beaucoup d'effets spéciaux donc ça met deux mois je crois d'effets spéciaux à faire et là on a une version finale,
étalonné, c'est à dire que les couleurs sont nickel, mixée, tout est parfait. Mais il y a une couille à un moment donné ! Dans la version actuelle du clip Natoo dit
à t'écouter rapper j'ai juste eu mal au crâne,
j'vais payer ma tournée, qui veux 100 milligrammes ?
Mais dans la version originale, elle ne disait pas ça, elle disait :
à t'écouter rapper j'ai juste eu mal au crâne,
J'vais payer ma tournée, qui veut un Doliprane ?
c'est pour ça que quand elle dit
100 mg ses lèvres ne suivent pas du tout le mot mais, on avait tout fait et on a dû modifier ça mec le seum intégral
Natoo elle a dû retourner en studio pour réenregistrer
la phrase, on à du la remixer, l'intégrer au clip, ça a retardé la sortie de la vidéo,
j'étais dégoûté, c'est des petits trucs mais vous savez pas comme c'est horrible quand ça tombe à la dernière minute,
en fait surtout c'est le truc qu'on aurait pu éviter
enfin bon bref, au final la vidéo vous a quand même hyper plu, elle a même marché à l'international,
il y a des Américains qui l'ont vu, des Anglais, bref toute la communauté Overwatch mondiale a entendu parler de cette vidéo
du coup je suis trop content, parce que c'est ce que je voulais, surtout en faisant cette vidéo c'était de faire kiffer les joueurs d'Overwatch,
en faisant un beau projet comme ça, je suis très content, voilà.
Les amis c'est la fin de cette vidéo, j'espère que ces petites anecdotes concernant ce que j'ai pu faire avec des marques, vous ont fait
marrer. OUI j'ai fait de la merde des fois et alors ? Mais à côté de ça il y a des trucs bien quand même
j'espère aussi avoir bien éclairé votre lanterne sur ce sujet, parce qu'il y a une paranoïa générale
avec les placements de produits et tout, parce qu'il y a des gens qui diabolise ça, alors que franchement maintenant tout est clairement dit en plus sur
Youtube les gens ils assument, ils disent voilà c'est sponso par bidule.
Alors ça veut pas dire qu'il faut aimer à tout prix, on a le droit de trouver que la vidéo est de la merde,
des fois c'est vraiment de la merde, et c'est scandaleux, je suis entièrement d'accord, je suis le premier à le dire, mais des fois il y a vraiment des trucs cool et
je comprends pas que les gens s'énervent. Si vous avez des questions en commentaire, hésitez pas, je trouve que c'est intéressant, je répondrais peut-être à quelques-uns.
Puis je vous fais plein de bisous, je vous dis a très vite dans une prochaine vidéo, puis j'espère que ce sera quand même été un peu
un peu intéressant pour vous, voilà.
C'est mon gel ça, ça c'est mon gel.
voilà moi l'argent, super !
(musique d'outro)